Biden's Beijing bailout that's the focus
of tonight's angle
[Music]
blast
I met a girl crazy for me
[Music]
yeah it was summer loving and she had
her a blast
three very productive days
very full days here in China I visited
iconic American companies like Boeing
and had a wonderful tour of Disney here
in Shanghai
and of course I met with my counterparts
from the PRC government
all of the meetings were productive I'm
happy to report
well this week binds Commerce Secretary
Gina raimondo was the latest in a long
line of senior bide Administration
officials who made their pilgrimages to
Beijing
now after this trip four days long it's
clear that this White House is just far
more excited about cooperating and
working with the Chinese Communist party
than they ever have been or ever will be
with the GOP
now Gina and Beijing established working
groups they announced a tourism Summit
but I think this was the angles favorite
we agree that technical experts from
China and from the U.S would convene to
strengthen protections for Trade Secrets
this trip is an excellent start
trying to get Trade Secrets protection
help from China
talk about the foxes guarding the hen
house
I mean do Democrats ever give
Republicans the benefit of the doubt
like they do with China uh the answer
would be no
and of course all the climate change
dances that Carrie's done with China
they're a complete joke and the Press
spin has been hilarious Politico cited
the fact that China committed to regular
conversations and that represents a
substantial step in restoring trust I
mean this is insane
we are on a suicide mission by aligning
ourselves against fossil fuels while
letting China buy oil and everything
else from Russia and Iran they're
swimming in oil
we all know what China wants what of
course we know this they want to
supplant America on the global stage in
part by beginning the process of
de-dollarization which would be a direct
hit to our middle class and the end of
America's superpower status talk about
that in a moment but the globalists
they're not preoccupied about what
happens to the working class here
certainly not worried about Americans
decline in general they're too worried
about China's economic problems which we
know are growing exponentially and
they're worried the Biden people about
managing China's decline
New York Times columnists and supposed
Republican Brett Stevens is just one of
many in the orbit pushing some type of
U.S bailout of Beijing
now let's drop the Trump tariffs on
Chinese Imports he argues because that
would be showing I love this American
economic magnanimity
regular people you don't get that
magnanimity but China should
now you cannot make this up think of
where we are right now with our trade
deficit with China it's a complete
nightmare we've gone from 308 billion
dollars in 2020 to
352.9 billion in 2021 and a staggering
382.3 billion last year
none of this is enough frankly for Janet
Yellen or Gina raimondo or Brett stevens
or anyone in the DC establishment in
fact I actually think they'd be happier
if we had an even bigger trade deficit
with China
and they'd be euphoric if we were even
more dependent on China for our supply
chains cheaper stuff that we can buy
here right
of course this means China will get even
richer and be able to buy even more
weapons and threaten more people
no matter what happens the answer from
The Establishment is always the same we
need more engagement with China
well is China booming we should have
more engagement with China
to show that China and the United States
can manage our differences
and to find ways to work together on
urgent Global issues
the United States stands ready to do
just that work with you if that's what
you desire
well let's do CCP level propaganda and
encourage Americans to invest in China
because that's what raimondo was doing
with her women executive meeting today
and is China supporting Russia and
Ukraine of course China is supporting
Russia and Ukraine that's no big deal
we've been very clear about Ukraine as
long as it takes I'm just not going to
get ahead of of a potential meeting that
uh Putin and president XI may have
ah now don't get ahead of that is China
committing genocide oh come on people
don't focus on the negative
we have candid open conversations
constructive conversations I was able to
explain U.S policies and our approach to
China what it is not is decoupling or
looking to hold back the Chinese economy
oh it doesn't matter it never matters
they're convinced that no matter what
happens no matter what China does we
must always and forever maintain good
relations with China never decouple
never think about decoupling
because they would rather have good
relations with the CCP than have good
relations with a 74 million Americans
who voted for Donald Trump
because they like the Communist Chinese
party and how they do business better
than they like the Trump voters and all
their old traditions
as long as they can get away with it
politically The Establishment will
always prioritize helping the CCP over
helping any of you in Middle America
all those lost manufacturing jobs they
weren't a mistake China's spectacular
growth over the years that wasn't a
mistake and China's ability to take our
technology threaten our position all
over Asia and the rest of the world that
wasn't a mistake that was all their
policy
this would still be their policy by the
way if it weren't for those four years
of Donald Trump and if they win in 2024
I promise you it will be their policy
again and that's the angle of course we
haven't even really gotten into the fact
that raimondo's four-day vacation in
Beijing was preceded by China at what's
called The Brick Summit the group of
Brazil Russia India China and the South
African Alliance that's trying to
Eclipse America and the G20 hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else